[Music]
it has been 14 years
since the first data is the new oil was
first used
this phrase was coined by cliff hamby
implying that
just as oil needs to be refined into gas
chemicals black plastics etc
data must be broken down and analyzed
for it to have value
but what if it is not of what value is
the data if it is open
if accessible but not usable
hi my name is sharmit karaoke and i'm
here to talk about a small
projector embarked on in march 2020.
arcana sensors is a package that
contains the 2019
kenya population and housing sensors
results
the population census exercise was held
in august
and this was the first time that kenya
was using technology
for both cartographic mapping and
enumeration
the survey questionnaire covered areas
such as population characteristics
agriculture education information
communication and technology
henceforth referred to as ict etc
this data was published in four pdf
files
which can be found on the kenya national
bureau of statistics website
now is this data open yes it is
available on the website
is it accessible yes anyone can download
it
but is it usable in its current format
but why do we even care why is usability
important let us look at one of the
aspects covered in the survey
ict we are going to look at the
influence that ict has had
on education in kenya during the covet
pandemic
but first a few statistics according to
a new report by unicef
two out of three school-age children do
not have internet access at home
in fact the number of unconnected
peoples is higher
in africa and asia as compared to the
rest of the world
the first copy case was announced in
kenya on 12th march
and two days after the government
announced closure of schools and
institutions were encouraged to move
their learning
online the ministry of education also
made a directive
for the curriculum teaching to be
delivered via radio tv
youtube and other digital platforms and
so
online learning began kenyans adapted
very quickly
one university trained their students
and staff and also entered into a
partnership with a mobile network
operator
to ensure that their staff received
cheaper data bundles
specifically for e-learning several
other institutions did their best to hit
to the government
directive entertainment programs were
aired on tv during school hours
and young kids quickly learned how to
use tools such as
zoom and google hangouts but then
online learning was not going well for
everyone leaders from semi-arid areas
came out claiming that online learning
in their areas was just better fallacy
because
their areas lacked basic infrastructure
so what basic infrastructure is required
for smooth
online learning first one will need a
laptop
or a mobile phone to access materials in
electronic format
and these devices have to actually be
connected to the internet so that you
can actually access this information
and electricity is needed to power both
a lot of students took to social media
to complain that
online learning was not working for them
a lot claimed that they lacked their
minimum basic requirements needed to
partake only learning
electricity has also been a problem in
kenya even for
us who have access to electricity it's
not reliable
i'm actually hoping that i'll be done
with this presentation by the time
lights go off you can visit um the kenya
power
twitter handle to just see more of the
complaints that
we channel through that platform
complaining about
blackouts uh day in day out
many families do not have the devices
and internet access that enable
children to take part in remote
schooling let's take an example of two
extreme cases manzie comes from an
average family
she has a bedroom of her own in their
house manzi's father
pays for internet at the end of each
month and he recently purchased a new
laptop for her
manzi attends srila kubwa which is a
university based in the capital city of
kenya nairobi
chile on the other hand comes from a
humble background
his parents are not able to pay school
fees for him and so he has to depend
on the areas but refund and after
imagine top
in the kenya secondary national
examination
charlie got a scholarship to also attend
scholar
so charlie and mandy together with some
of the
friends they grew up with are in the
same class and while in school
they are subjected to the same
conditions the same lecture room the
same lecture period
the same exam and so on but what happens
now that they're at home
well mandy is actually very happy she
gets to seclude herself in her room
during
class sessions and while on her break
she's able to enjoy her favorite comedy
on netflix but then for charlie he's
actually depressed he's even thinking of
repeating the current class because he
feels
he has been left behind
after six months schools reopened for a
small subset of students
those preparing for the national
examinations in kenya national
examination
examinations take place at the end of
each year
now an effective education response to
the copy 19 pandemic
needs to be built on evidence and data
for example
what do we know about our population how
many families own radios and televisions
and do children actually
use and actually learn from these online
platforms
and that's why the development of our
kenya sensors
was important development of this
package involved
three steps the first one was
downloading the data from the
kenya national bureau of statistics
website
the second one involved cleaning
scrapping cleaning and manipulating the
data i used the tabulaizer package to
scrap the data
anti-device and some bizarre functions
for cleaning and manipulating it
the third step was the actual package
development and i'm very grateful to the
others of devtools test that
and use this who have made package
development very easy
i'm also grateful to hadley and jenny
for
the art packages book that is written in
such a simple
language such such that it is easy to
understand
some of the concepts covered
for consistency the data sets were named
in a similar manner as the tables in the
published document so
v1 and s42.1 is actually
table 2.1 in volume 1. data cleaning and
manipulation skills are really important
in this task
i had to deal with a lot of trailing and
leading spaces
extra white spaces land spaces and other
weird characters
i also needed to restructure the data by
generating new variables that
distinguished
counties from sub-counties i'm grateful
to the r4ds community especially
scott and stephen who are of great help
and i encountered errors
while coding well i still battle with
rejects up to date
i also created a small shiny app where
anyone especially those who do not use r
could download the data in
either dot csv or dot x format
now could some of this data have helped
us to determine whether kenya
was ready for online learning let's have
a look
this map shows the proportion of
households where the main type of
lighting is the electricity
the data can be found in volume four
table two point one
nine so in essence in the data it's
going to be v4 underscore 2.19
the darker the region the higher the
proportion
the darkest region is the capital city
of kenya which is nairobi
most regions in the semi-arid areas
that's the light yellow
regions use either burnt wood torches or
paraffin lamps
as a source of light charlie comes from
one of these areas
in case anyone is curious these maps are
created using
sfng plot tool the pattern is the same
when we look at
access to computers or laptops and usage
of the internet
semi-arid and regions that have high
population based in the rural areas tend
to be at a disadvantage
there's no way charlie could have ripped
the benefits of online learning as much
as
manzi would have even at a bare minimum
if this kind
of analysis was available beforehand the
insights
obtained could have helped the
government and stakeholders make better
decisions regarding learning
during the covert pandemic the data has
been used by
the international center for
humanitarian affairs which is part of
the red cross
to assess covet maintain high risk areas
in kenya
it may appear that most entities will
adopt this data to develop insights that
will help
drive development in kenya and to
conclude
we have only touched on the ict part of
this
data in essence only two out of 74
tables
imagine how much information we could
get if we analyzed
all the sensors data and imagine how
much more information and insights we
could get
if we converted all the datasets that
are aligned in various websites
into machine readable formats that are
easy to
analyze insights obtained from this data
will help the country
prepare itself better for the left
column meeting
r is an open source language and there
are so many learning resources online
it's up to us as our developers and our
users to use the knowledge and skills we
have
to develop tools that will help us in
solving problems that exist in our
society
thank you for listening to me questions
are welcome
[Music]